i was getting into an elevator with one
of my staffers
and he and i are we're leaving the
capitol when i see a capitol police
officer
running hurriedly
to the elevator i see threat all over
his face i look to my left and there she
is
ilhan omar
and i said well
she doesn't have a backpack we should be
fine
[Applause]
all right the emergence of that video
which seemed to be a joke albeit maybe
an insensitive one predictably sent the
media into total meltdown mode
bobert who proudly displayed her
ignorance and bigotry and comments about
minnesota democrat ilhan omar bobert has
a troubling track record of making vile
and incendiary comments the
normalization of islamophobia by the
republican party has been going on for
20 years it's a garbage comment from a
garbage
politician this sort of rhetoric
contributes to threats against her she
can be censured i think that she should
be stripped of her committees
they always want to cancel people
congresswoman bobert called to apologize
to congressman omar yesterday but the
call went off the rails omar said in a
statement congressman bobert refused to
publicly acknowledge her hurtful and
dangerous comments she instead doubled
down on her rhetoric and i decided to
end the unproductive call
colorado congresswoman lauren bobert
joins me now exclusively
congresswoman other than the part about
her hanging up on you
is any part of what she said there true
uh look laura i called to speak with her
directly about me reflecting on my
comments about her i had made a public
statement but she didn't want to hear
what i had to say um and her press
release um really was like it was
drafted before the phone call even had
took place um omar and the left don't
want an apology they want public
humiliation they want to cancel me but
that's not going to happen laura i want
to say this to you and the millions of
americans who watch this show i will not
be canceled we all know why cnn and the
left want to focus on these distractions
it's because they have no winning issues
to talk about democrats can't talk about
skyrocketing inflation or the invasion
at our southern border they can't talk
about the americans still stranded in
afghanistan they can't talk about the
supply chain shortages workforce
shortages or gas shortages why can't
they talk about these crises because
they caused each and every one of them
democrat policies have failed one party
order for one year and they are failing
every single american so they'll focus
on ilhan's outrage rather than the
outrage of the american people who are
suffocating under biden's failed regime
so isn't it important then that
and look we all
say things that are a little bit
outrageous every now and then um so
you're young you just arrived in
washington uh but they're gonna come
after you because they think you're a
threat you're an america first
conservative they don't like you they
never did they're never going to you're
never going to win accolades from the
elites they hate you um but you can't
give them a bat to hit you over the head
with either which you kind of did with
those comments
do you recognize that
uh i think my statement reflects um
exactly that i i didn't apologize to
appease ilhan or the left or nancy
pelosi or anyone else i did that because
i'm here to be a good congresswoman for
the people who sent me here to be their
voice the people who sent to send me to
secure their freedoms they know that
i'll defend israel and support our
police unlike others who call israelis
terrorists and want to dismantle the
police i'll protect your right to keep
and bear arms unlike ilhan omar who
supports the government coming to your
door and confiscating your guns i
believe that life is the most precious
gift from god and others like ilhan have
voted for abortion up to and even after
a child is born i support law and order
and ilhon supports ending cash bail and
putting more hardened criminals on the
street like the psycho who ran over
children in waukesha wisconsin these
policies are dangerous the policies that
i disagree with ilhan omar are dangerous
and her police her policies attack our
allies and support terrorists
congresswoman i have an idea why don't
you challenge her to a debate
i would love a debate i would love to
regular order in the people we'll do it
on this show we'll do it right here on
the show now
that would be absolutely fantastic yeah
i will step up because these are
yes these are the dangerous policies
that are [ __ ] crippling our nation and
it's it's disheartening to see someone
who hates america serving in the united
states of representatives i love america
and at the end of the day that is the
fundamental difference here and i would
be happy to accept that invitation to
have a debate right here on your show
with congresswoman ilhan omar now she
held a press conference
about this incident tonight she's not
going to let it go of course here's just
a little piece
we cannot pretend
that this hate speech from leading
politicians doesn't have real
consequences the truth is that
anti-muslim hate is on the rise both
here at home and around the world
congresswoman bobert she was elected to
congress
and your response to this are you
anti-muslim
oh absolutely not and i apologize to the
muslim community and even ohan omar
brought up a man who was calling with
death threats and i fully believe that
that man needs to be found by capitol
police and held fully accountable
just like the men who have called with
death threats against my family against
my staff my restaurant all in the past
few days they need to be found and held
accountable and
you know how that's going to happen
by our brave law enforcement officer who
i officers who i fully support and who
ilma elhan has disparaged and worked to
defund
i certainly do not criticize anyone's
religion or faith and that is exactly
why i released my statement to the
muslim congressman
one would think that given what's
happened in minneapolis
and the rising crime murder rate
you know everything that's happening in
minneapolis post george floyd
one would think that congresswoman elon
omar would kind of focus on that
especially after the defund the police
thing went down in flames in that
referendum
but you're the focus
you're the focus of elon omar right
because her policies are failed and uh
and even minnesota is seeing that and
that's why we're seeing the defund the
police movement go away because we do
need our law enforcement officers we
deeply slam and
gone down congresswoman
we gotta run but we appreciate your
clearing things up and coming on the
show tonight hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else